[Music] what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we're here for genv episode
4 John you good genuinely Greg Co you got a
g-w graciously vivacious I got a GW G fuel
gfuel today ladies and gentlemen sincerely one of
the best Brands we've ever worked with because I
consume their products daily so much to the
point that they send over a monthly order to
me every month but whenever I run out I find
myself running to whatever random store might
have it available and I end up buying more myself
yes a lot of people have talked to me about like
hey Greg you look like you've been getting a lot
healthier how do you manage that while doing all
the work that you do really a lot does come
down to this product right here I'm giving a
very sincere shout out for good reason if you
don't want to rush to a store like myself you
want to get it delivered to you efficiently and
a great way to support the channel on top of
all that you can use our special discount code
in the description box and pin comment to get
yourself some G fuel today it's the best I hope
we can work with them for as long as this channel
exists because I am very dependent on them and
these guys get themselves some can shipped in
them now as well we're not even kidding cuz we
come here and be like I want a can and Greg be
like well then I'll run out of mine earlier and
he's like I bet you guys get some okay yell at
them we bring cans ourselves out of fear yeah koi
panes cans on camera all right guys well let's get
to it before we do please go ahead and leave a
like as always full lrat and watch along where
you sync with your own copy of gen V available
for super sex rejects over at our patreon page
cover things exclusive over there reaction Hots
and watch along is included and oh yeah subscribe
click that notification B get notifi when our
reaction for the next episode J's up let's get to
it are we in an ear what a
POV oh oh wow we are I know the inside of
ear looks like I use an ear wax thing maybe
Sam penetrated the year canal with the his
m oh yeah Sam skull here he's a big scary
movie fan Sam's stronger than G boy ever
was I don't know how to contain someone
like that that's painfully obvious oh wow
they don't mess up the facility oh yeah WS
no more it's a great shot I want the whole
security team on this well half of them are
dead then use the other half little booty
no he got a good eye no yeah no a you left
a shoe behind evidence she'd know the students
she got got out of the hell hole it looks like
a meteor crashed here maybe Sam can jump
like ma does he landed here with Emma and
then jumped again I'd love that guy's voice
it's very peaceful maybe he jumped like M
us we don't know who's in on it if Brink was
maybe other professors maybe Dean shett but
you guys are going to get a green van and
a talking dog and Sol it that's right gang
I told you not to do anything stupid why don't
you ever then listen to this girl could be dead
Andre we are in over our heads just push him
to listen to you next time in over our heads
how do you guys expect to rest to the rank of
superhero get on the list I like how they're
subverting The Jock pretty girl like they're the
kindest and like the most empathetic you look a
little bigger did you grow think I must have
swallowed something when I went through that
guy's head brains I killed that guy he he was
a sadistic [__] does that make you feel any
better what if he had kids wow the first person
she ever killed you think there's a phone in
here somewhere I mean we need help oh no I I
there's only one person who can help I I I I
got to get a hold of Luke yeah about that your
brother died what are you talking about nothing
could kill Luke he's he's he's he's too strong
wrong only Luke can kill Luke himself wait no
sorry
yes good thing you're tiny right now
supero superhero
Landing I'm here Sam you leave too I won't
don't get near him you will he'll flick you away
everybody always leaves me promise I'm with you
I wonder how they filmed this with them because
it really feels like they're two actors in the
same room scattered Clues and hidden corners of
Darkness oh oh no fought plus I'm Tech Knight and
I won't stop searching hey did you hear that TCH
Knight oh [__] truth he's like a billionaire
Iron Man Batman inspiration first appearance
but good oh definitely you can test the most
moral great Bruce Wayne standing but tragedy
has rocked this institution to its core the rising
star who took life but why did the Golden Boy Who
had everything this whole case is a rabbit hole
into the unknown and I won't stop plunging its
depths he does a lot of Robin boning that's a
lot of sorry K guys car plunging its depths I
mean what come on let's go again let's reset I
like him already it's an honor to have such an
esteemed alumnus back with us [__] you hate that
I'm here I make you nervous seems like you want to
make her nervous was it iron cast who himself
the morning after you interrogated him strange
how many of your subjects and stand up dead or
beaten into Comas I myself have nothing to hide
are you sure about that small beat of sweat on
your brow detective adrenaline seeping from your
pores and you're ovulating by the way o she's
adductive what has Ashley told you did she tell
me that Golden Boy killed Brink in a misguided
attempt to rescue his brother from the woods so
you know exactly why it's our job to make sure
no no one else knows and how do you intend to
do that well the usual misdirection opusc find
a py and destroy their life pick a card any card
I'm going to Johnny dab someone so hard they're
going to want to crawl into a hole and die nice
just stay away from the top five ouch Jesu christe
there's always more where they came from you'll
manage those giant de channels are going to have
plenty of content oh yeah a lot of people buying
new houses now I'm I'm going to need access to
campus surveillance a full list of golden boys
classmates girlfriends a couple of reflectors from
the film department yes Roy forgot our bounces got
to get that soft light boy quality life for Tech
Knight I hope he brought his Ward I like his szy
charm but he didn't just Batman disappear on
her he got cuz he's Bruce Wayne right now kind
of that's fair I like the Sherlock choice of the
zoom inss too you look high but me no not at all
sorry what are you on and I'm sorry I should have
listened I don't know where Emma is and I don't
know what to do that might also be a tiny bit nice
you guys are way too comfortable with each other
he just died and my dad knows about the woods what
they're doing and he told me to drop it maybe he
trying to protect you well yeah protect and cover
up this whole time he was mixed up in all this
he's not the man that I thought he was you don't
know if he's mixed up in it or if he just knows
about it yeah what do he tell you sheth's lover
was a handsome arrogant venture capitalist and
now staying on the floor of his Chef's Kitchen
was his demise crushed under all 700 lb of his
girlfriend Jesus smothering the drag Forest ruus
right I heard you're a psychic yeah think jamanji
baseball backa so you're looking for your roommate
but she's not the only girl you're looking for
sister I don't have any money there are other ways
you can thank me yes let's do this extortion hey
come on I'm [__] with you is that his quote
I can see your friend is is she okay she looks
rough come closer I need a stronger connection
come a little closer than you see how does her
connection make it strong sketchy guy this dude's
like an Aryan Ramy mik open the godamn swear to
God whoa what is happening off I'm busy oh no
what the it's not what it looks like whoa on
Earth that's a spicy meat ball what what did she
blood B the thingy I think she did nice work come
on where the blood was flowing jeez wow oh I'm
so disoriented right that was so much that was
random you're really going to throw it all away
I'm not throwing it all away I'm not but Emma's
my friend what happened to you don't owe anyone
anything and to leave you the alone maybe I was
wrong maybe you're an idiot you idiot you're full
of [__] [__] she can't help you you know I'm
right you're just scared I hope these two hook
up Tech night is on campus if he finds out what
you're doing you're lucky you end up in prison he
people up since when do you care about anyone not
named Jordan cared about Luke how do you guys
move on past what just happened so fast know
what's going on you guys are just like it's just
another day exploded his okay we're back because
I distracted him tag team explosion essay must be
a big just thing that happens constantly in this
world with pow it is in the comic and I imagine
in college but combination's a lot five four
three why did he do it Andre I don't know I think
it's obvious he couldn't hack it hack it you're
stronger than all of us well that must have been
hard for you knowing that You' never beat him oh
it's fine oh interesting if he wasn't at this
school you would have been number one maybe I
don't know prank would have made sure of it ouch
oh man you are a provocator have you always been
angry at Golden Boy no I loved him you gave
your whole life to him who's going to break
how did you not know he was this Disturbed wish
I had known it kills me that I missed it take
that glove off I take your hand off what did
he say to you just before he died daddy loved
me tell the LIE how long have you been eating
golden boys girlfriends whoa who whoa who who
man the number one spot he found out about
you and Kate cracked no no that didn't happen
until so it did happen no you get treated
like a god here what kind of hero chicken
[__] to do anything heroic oh damn are we
going to have like actual Heroes out of our
soups it's up to the Next Generation man we'll
find it in the edit I also love that his power
of deduction is like that specific it's a good
Batman joke it's like superp power but he's a
human it's embarrassing you know I'm not the
best judge for what's humiliating I used to
put stuff up my butt for money I'm kidding
yeah no it wasn't for money after what you
did for me I would eat your puke I take it
back you are sick I know multiple Mental
Hospitals a so well cast what if under my shirt
it was all nipple like your nipple so big it
band your whole torso no like a triple nipple
except it's a Quin quadruple nipple what if I
just had like 50 nipples under my shirt I can live
with that do you let's see things I worry about
please stop [Music] no shut
up I do worry about his sanity your roommate's
Emma she's the one who gets small why have you
seen her recently stays the night at this guy
Austin's place every night what's this about
I'm just checking she's okay she missed a few
classes it's scary to lie when there's a lie
detector on campus we are fortunate to have a
guest lecturer who revolutionized the field in
superhero crime fighting so sweet Tech Knight
on camera to walk back today we will focus on
interrogation techniques that I developed what is
it with the the the Rings I will need a volunteer
choose the one who's not raising their hand this
is going to go poorly for anyone yep one of the
five Marie Maro the guardian of gulan walk me
through that day I've told this story a lot but
not the whole story Jordan why were you going to
see Brink I wanted to discuss my class schedule
damn it can you control the blood flow in your
oh and your ocular yeah is that nerve not dilate
was it to talk about his distaste for you Bullseye
heart rate just elevated wow you can really teach
this to other people can't you people with this
detective skill he was going to expel you wasn't
he no were you in on it with Luke no I didn't
do anything now or then then now both is it I
couldn't stop Luke uhoh I went to Brinks because
he kicked me out I saw Luke and iing ran the only
reason I'm still alive is because Jordan Lee
held him off long enough for me to get away
wow is this all going to be on VA plug on camera
right now does Jordan's ranking go up Jordan's the
hero not me and that's how you break a witness
folks but only you can pull that off yeah it's
literally a power so you know you're going to
want to zoom in hyperfocus on their arteries
smell their adrenaline their pupil no one will
believe Marie Maro is responsible for Golden Boy
demise I can't pin this on any of these kids pity
for your show you should interrogate her which is
why I'm going to pin it on you I shouldn't go
after the top five they could be real earners
ohug you have no evidence I've done anything wrong
what about Sam escaping from the woods hell yeah
yeah I saw it on your face when I first brought up
his name wait till vaud finds out I'd say taking
the fall for Golden Boy is getting off easy does
she have a secret superpower if she's the dean
I have to imagine she would so in the comics
he's like super horny and there's some stuff
with Robin I don't remember the like the amount of
Bruce Wayne I'm really curious how they land that
oh he crazy crazy please no can't run forever
you know a little bit like black noir going to
find you and hurt you again Jason Ritter Jason
Ritter Jason Ritter oh it'll be all your fault
you couldn't protect her no won let them there's
only one way to make sure AVU Fe this is great you
know who hurt you he hurts everyone in the woods
a Dr cardosa ding ding ding somehow it's creepier
as a puppet well it's playing on the childhood
innocence here just just just shut up television
Jason R Dr cardosa haven't you been listening
he's dangerous and I have to stop him no no more
talking some great editing here he hurt me and
he won't leave me Al alone okay Sam I don't know
what's wrong what can I do how can I help you keep
just stop just stop please stop stop oh no man oh
dude my God no he's hulking
away oh didn't repair the crotch don't need
to [Music] I'm crushing your head oh oh
public don't know what I do without you
oh it's nothing in that case you're welcome for
nothing this is not good to do in public guys
no he he just died I didn't ask you to do that
yeah you did specifically several times actually
but I didn't want you to bury yourself in the
process you keep doing the dumb thing [Music]
my angle is that sometimes people don't have
an angle sometimes they're just actual human
beings what what's the everyone's got a motive
I was just talking [__] okay you're the only
one who actually Golden Boy yeah but I'm so scared
you guys should comfort each other Craig has goals
I have motives yes yes oh oh you don't need
to change which one either or knew it called
it I'm sorry that's not what you meant yo you
pull them in no pull them in come out yeah come
out good for Jordan good for her it's interesting
for this guy hey we we just need you on set for
the kissing scene can you just click back in
thanks my hook H up radar is so strong dude
oh a lot is happening true that sister she's
still bloody sorry Sam's going after Dr cusa
we have to stop him who Luke's brother it's
actually kind of hot no who car do he used to
work with Brink I know where he lives oh [__]
know where he lives did you recently visit the
brain tumor Center at John's Hopkins you have
a small tumor in your brain will eventually
be fatal but I imagine you already know that
i' Hazard compilation of your greatest hits
is's he doing stuff with this stuff he is
do stuff full shaped stuff yes Corey your
18 to 49 demo will fare when we broadcast
you despoiling every single hole you come
across what you you want there's nothing
to find at God you or with me nothing to
tell V and no reason to stay long as you're
off campus by end of day this video stays
off Instagram hell yeah she's like the meline
still well it's easier to proe the dark hole of
conspiracy my man dark hole fortunately gulan
University remains as resilient as [Laughter]
ever with this case behind me I move on
to the next mystery to seek out the whole
truth oh my god dude oh man uh give me a
few minutes alone please how what did you
the tree is right here it's a compulsion
it's a compulsion oh you know Batman may
not do certain things to Catwoman but
this Batman does plenty I noticed when
he said the 20 years since he's been at
class that program that there was a sense
of existentialism and his delivery and then
now finding about the tumor makes a lot more
sense s look at me look at me
murder him Sam you're not real
you're all puppets I don't want to
oh man this jarring editing yeah oh
God go go go go Sam Sam I'm here
look at me oh wow damn oh we're
X-Men sham Sam you don't want to do this you
don't want to do this Sam Sam you said I was
your hero okay let me help you again no
they're not this is problem hey guys some
sensitivity some sensitivity dude dude [Music]
ow O [Music] no can she get bigger oh my God
giant woman is she got a giant [Music] woman oh
man keep now you're fighting the brother [Music]
whoa she H we love Luke when we found out
he was trying to rescue you we tried to
help damn giant girl let me go that's
disturbing wherever we go we promise
we're in this together Sam we're going
to make this right I promise we'll oh
no what the hell is going on
whoa
what God no my dude no no with
it on yeah accessories [Music]
tools of course gotta leave us with
a little Moment of Zen what uh what
happened did they pull in the psychic guy to
to like neutralize the situation bring them
all and I don't know what just happened how
we went to the bed yeah from the it's exactly
like the cut with the psychic guy so I
wonder if either somebody else has his
similar power or if they brought him in as
their neutralizer or something I'm confused
this this is this interesting episode I
was like is there something wrong with
the footage I was like did the internet cut
out like it felt like a disassoc what just
happened I'm still confused narratively I cannot
explain that Derek Wilson I hope he's related to
the other Wilson because he's incredible what
just happened how were they in bed how did
they get what how did they leave the house they
were X-Men yeah um all right I guess let's try
to take in what just happened yeah I need to I'm
immediately like Message Board reading in my head
like what is it I rarely want to read what people
are thinking but I'm like what just happened that
was intentional right you must well there was the
music cut and everything yeah yeah no it's because
that threw in his little Montage too is implying
that it's like a a jump cut of like you know sexy
time but like what narratively I don't understand
yeah I don't I don't get it they just needed some
way to end the episode and then next time they'll
cut back to midf fight then show us the chronology
of how they all got back yeah like there must be
a reason cuz she was like mids sentence which like
we know how the sentence ended so they cut it off
at a place that we'd understand what was going
to happen next but then the jump cut and then the
further jump cut implies there has to be something
to like narratively explain like is there a
psychic like you said is there like maybe that's
the dean's P what's happening but why would the
psychic do specifically that like when the time
Omission was explained through strong pheromones
with her getting like assaulted and then you know
explosion unless of course it might have been
a memory wipe situation could be you know where
like they actually retriev Sam and then they wipe
the memories of them yeah it could be and so they
were playing it like okay from the moment because
what what happened is that Jordan and Marie were
about to hook up and then cricet came in and oh
and now they've got cricket and yeah like they
took cricket and Sam yeah or or like so it's like
okay let's just wipe the memory and then just put
them in bed together so that way that's when they
that's so clever if that's if that's what happened
I'm just making it guess it's an interesting thing
to have that twice in an episode because once it
was pheromones now it's like a mind wipe but they
did talk about mind wiping people in the episode
first two oh yeah they they WIP they mind wiped
about Sam prior and yeah so maybe it was like the
Jordan moment was about to they were about to
get after it and then they just wiped back to
them finishing yeah yeah in the Doctor's house too
yeah maybe they had some kind of woods related you
know like alarm or something he can sound that'll
get people in there and then yeah maybe they can
just wipe the memories Place everybody back and
then clean up this mess and that was pretty public
like the doctor was alive he would have called
somebody yeah yeah and it's like you know the
mess of them breaking in is like yeah that puts
their like careers and and and their you know
schooling at risk but at the same time you know
I feel like it also stands to it stands a threat
to revealing the woods and what's really going on
down there so maybe they did just like clean this
up and then yeah probably take Sam and cricket
and imprison them and all the jaring editing for
his Insanity was like that translates into like
you know us being disoriented which they use well
for the edit but now us being disoriented got to
be purposeful yeah yeah maybe the psychic thing
was a mislead maybe it could be to make you
think it might have been that like the like
the jump cut earlier was disorienting so this or
maybe they mind WIP via psychic maybe they use
psychic to mind wipe oh yeah maybe he's how they
do it I thought it was I thought it was really
odd placement it didn't feel like an intentional
jump cut well I think I'm saying like the use of
the psychic in this episode I thought was just
odd in total like okay I understand her talking
to the psychic to but it did seem like a forced
DSX Machina like we need this thing yeah like and
for another you know gross out bit um that that
the boys Universe does and and then they they're
kind of imp passive reaction to I'm like I still
feel like they would be very uh disturbed by what
just happened at least Marie even though I know
they seem some horrible [__] but that is a very
disturbing you know sexually graphic violent thing
to suddenly witness and go through and to uh also
um do to someone even though it is uh protecting
yourself essentially uh it's so I'm like okay this
whole thing just kind of feels it felt like off to
me I'm like all right I get gross out gag humor in
the boys but this whole thing feels like just odd
uh instead of fitting um but maybe that was placed
to establish the psychic side of it and then they
use a PSY and I hope so yeah yeah because there's
a time because there is a a gap there for Marie
when she is on the bench to now she's in because
it almost plays like a vision when you first are
there then it's not actually a vision it's a thing
that's really happening yeah time removal it's
like the initial jar of that moment does work I
think in editing where it's like oh we were just
on the bench and now we're here what's going on
but yeah it's the H it's the handling of the gag
that feels a bit strange and it feels like one
of those bits of like yeah it's well within this
universe for this guy to be a complete creep but
at the same time we got to get like a weird gor
gag we haven't had a weird gor gag in a while and
a gross sex one it's been 40 minutes since a day
we got to bring in a we got to do one somewhere
you know and then let's get back to the plot you
know yeah yeah um overall this episode felt the
most uh disorganized obviously besides those
two cuts but if that was the purpose I would
really like it like in the greater scheme of the
Season like if it was intentionally disorganized
and messy because all the tech Knight stuff was
also very efficient and lean like they did really
good editing around like you know intermixing like
his lore and backstory and like Tech knight uh you
know has that same fetish uh SL disorder in the
comic and I I missed his name dropped so like I
I missed the initial joke but once I realized who
he was like that was really played well so it's
not like the episode was messy but I think enough
was messy I'm hoping it was conscious well the
episode's perspective is that of like paranoia
what is real what isn't real the entire time
you know from Sam's perspective of constantly
questioning what is reality the way they play
with the psychic of what is real what isn't real
even with tech Knight of trying to uncover the
truth of behind everyone's deception and lies
and lesser even Aaron discovering like you know
how deep this goes them trying to unravel that
mystery and then all them being disoriented by
Tech Knight being able to rip things apart like
even the interrogation is its own way like truths
being revealed like disorienting yeah yeah strange
very strange episode yeah no it was Str is it is
very strange and I guess like watching however
episode five plays out would be a little bit
more telling of how this one um ultimately factors
into the bigger equation of things it's funny that
the first three were we were saying like week
one two and three could have been separate but
this episode form like the next one like yeah this
feels the least like its own you could watch each
of the they're all part of an ongoing story but
each of them feels well-rounded in isolation up
to this point and this one certainly feels like
okay this is like you know another interstitial
chapter on the way to the next part of the plot
uh it it has that feeling of like yeah we learned
some stuff you know we we rubbed up against a new
potential villain and the most like progress we
made was at least getting Sam out and and and that
situation but we don't really even know how that
ends up right now it seems like he's most likely
back in you know the the woods so I feel like in a
way it is one of those more like let's explore
some Stakes let's explore some uncomfortable
situations for the characters but it doesn't feel
as much like we're moving things along as in in a
way that it it felt like it was going to I don't
know like when they all have that showdown at the
end I was like oh damn we're already getting to
something like this you know we're already kind
of and I'm sure there will be a reward to the
you know rug pool at the very end but as it
stands just right now like yeah it it does kind
of I don't know what to call it because it's not
filler you know because it's still doing things
for the characters and it's still expounding on
things but it doesn't feel as substantial as
just like oh yeah you know like I could have
like we've said of the past three episodes I
could have taken one of these and just chewed
on it all week you know I think it's good though
for the internet culture to have something like
this though because now every instead of having
the first three at once everybody talked about
it a little bit and now everyone that jumped on
the first three episodes this is the first time
they've been like well I have to wait a week
and everyone is going to be saying like did
yours break too like I feel like Twitter is gonna
be like really alive waiting for a week for this
this might build an audience this might grow it
because it's everyone now waiting going like what
the hell yeah sure that's a good that's a good
time to break it up is like have your three that
feel like you've got some closure wait have one
that's insanely disorienting grow your audience
even more because everybody's discourse yeah well
I think there I I just think there are some beats
though because a lot about it that I loved I mean
I love Tech Knight's portrayal I I think like um
like a Bruce Wayne who's like out in public and
showing he's got powers instead of like uh dual
identity and it except his like hidden identities
that he he's like a pervert Psychopathic per he's
like he's more of like if Bruce Wayne was American
Psycho yeah and I really like that portrayal and
I think the actor did a fantastic job of of like
with his on camera presence and his public charm
really does shine but it meshes well with when
the camera's not rolling as well I think he was
excellent and and um I I liked uh the the action
moments were cool I really like I can't remember
her freaking name which one Cricket yeah Emma Emma
Emma yeah I really like Emma here and um even the
reveal of her power which it seemed like a lot
of people weren't aware that she could actually
do herself uh was really was really cool like the
exact opposite effect you know consume now great
on TV and biging she's my favorite character for
sure I think she's great I think she's amazing
and I I love her chemistry as well with Sam and
there's some just little beats like I said I
don't want to harp too much on that one beat with
the psychic that I thought was really odd but I I
did think it was odd though that not much of
a even though my radar was like yeah they're
going to hook up when it came I thought it was a
little odd um other than like I thought we were
still building sexual tension with them like it'd
be the next time like that would be like someone
would come in the room they'd stop then next yeah
I didn't think it would be like oh it's happening
now and and and then the also the Revelation that
she she did unveil not not just to Tech Knight but
to a bunch of people in the room yeah and with
CER present at least but the cameras aren't live
right they're it is a recording so yeah I imagine
it's just be in the room but people people in the
room yeah those people in the room you think that
would be more the next day at school she's like
number Revelation Stakes at hand here and ammo
for fellow students to use against her climb R
yeah yeah so I thought there would be a little
bit more and maybe there will be it just kind
of felt a little inconsequential and only only to
the drama between Jordan and Marie which just led
to them hooking up seems like a real positive
that she told everyone that she doesn't have
powers yeah so uh yeah that that moment still
played a little strange to me as well uh but
because it's like episode four out out of what
eight eight that I'm I'm sort of just waiting
to see how it factors in versus versus judging
you know what the overall narrative is with it
but right now yeah there's just a couple of things
I played a little bit whereas like the other ones
I didn't really have much of a critical criticism
towards we here I'm like kind of a little little
suspicious of how some things are going to play
out and if they're actually good or effective
but still overall I really enjoyed my time here
um yeah sometimes I do and I I kind of feel this
way with the boys too sometimes I I feel like you
guys probably eat up some of the more like gross
out gags more than I do for me sometimes I'm like
I don't know I'm like it's kind of amusing but the
times it does feel like they're they're they're
just doing it to do it I mean it ratings yeah
no that's how I felt about this one here like I
I I'm not you know bring me a a macro eggplant
Emoji you know like I'm not necessarily like
coming to the show for that stuff that's not
necessarily my my flavor like that I seek out
I can enjoy that but here yeah no like that gag
while you know wild and shocking you know didn't
really add much to the even the holes joke thing
was kind of like all right well I that's so the
comic was very much of the time of how much can
we push a boundary and I I think I explained this
episode one but this was when everyone was doing
commentary on stuff so this became a commentary
on the commentary almost like once scary movie
had done seven scary movies there was things
making fun of scary movie I feel like the boys
was the thing that was like okay we've got the
authority we've got the Supreme uh Squad I forget
the last but we've got all these commentaries
on team books and the boys was like we want to
look at the overall comic industry and Perry but
we're going to instead of pushing the violence or
the political commentary we're going to push the
gross out because 2006 was like the age of gross
out sexualization stuff so I feel like the show uh
the boys was able to saiz that politically and to
change everything to being like a commentary on
our pop culture system whereas this show is more
of a commentary on College and like growing up but
it does tie more into sexualization more directly
so they're able to do a lot more of the comic
stuff which is then in turn hypersexualizing gross
out stuff so honestly this feels more directly
akin to the boys comic than the boys does but
it also seems like an opportunity for some of the
sensibilities a very 06 time to be like what if
dick jokes every episode like it seems very much
that so it does feel more like the the comic but
the comic feels very of a time so I don't know how
much this translates but I think it's also great
for the ratings for Amazon to have a dick joking
episode like everyone's going to be talking about
exploding sure like it's just it works narratively
for the sales with which is Amazon ironically the
vot parallel here yeah yeah vot plus is selling D
I mean the the whole thing is a bit more of like
a character Trope or character beat for him so
like yeah I don't know like th those things are
all they work on me but I wouldn't say they're
like a draw for the holes thing worked for me
better than the exploding D they make me squirm
and laugh but yeah the whole thing is direct
like there I remember a double page spread in
the comic of like it lands the the final bit
is him uh going at Robin and I was like like it
was very very a lot in the comic book and this
was like I was really worried for some poor Ward
oh yeah but that'd be a great Joseph Gordon Le
came fair enough oh to live on that timeline fair
enough Donal whoever oh like any Robin like stand
in like it' be funny if it was the more obscure
uh I mean generally I like the just to clarify
generally I like the the vulgarity yeah generally
I really enjoy it um but but it works times where
I feel like it's a little forced it works best
when it's narratively serving whereas this felt
like they were like it's been a little bit yeah
yeah when you believe it's a part of this world
that you happen to be passing through not
yeah like we need to drop one of these in
here cuz that's what we do yeah I I would say
of the episodes this was my least favorite but
it's in part because of all the things we just
mentioned but also I do feel like it is suffering
from it needs to be talked about before the next
episode this one's the only one that feels kind of
incomplete sure yeah but maybe that's the point
I think it is it's the start of act to yeah and
it's like it's it's it's a show not a movie in a
way I feel like if you're shifting away from okay
we just dropped three now we got to drop one
I think maybe there's a strategy in dropping
one that feels like this may improve with f the
upcoming episodes or something like the context
of this might solidify itself and calcify when
we get to the rest of what's happening I think
we'll get the rest of the puzzle next episode
I I think I think they should have made it it
would have served to help make it clear what what
happened in that cut it like is it a memory are
they do they not remember what happened did
they just go back and hook up guess I guess I
would have ended it there instead of tagging
it with tech Knight because then I think the
mystery lingers a little bit because let's say
it is memory wipe and they don't remember then
it then then it's like o what like how'd that
happen you and I would have been more jarring
to have them in bed together then credits than
the joke yeah mid credits the yeah the joke yeah
I would throw the tech KN at the post credit
like I'd throw that at the end and then you've
got that like what's happening and it feels more
resolved than a montage yeah yeah totally yeah it
was a little weird cuz it's like a double button
yeah it's like why are we doing two bits and also
why is there a songs these things don't connect
yeah totally no it's the most sort of uh it's the
least refined episode it's it's like it's one
of those things where it's like all the things
I've Loved about the show so far are in here and
like there's lots of good work in here but yeah
it's just like the proportions don't feel as sad
satisfying as everything up till now but not in a
way that makes me go oh no the show's dropping
off or or you know well because we had some uh
worries and criticisms that means we hated it we
hated it let the record show come and we always
hate everything too unless we love every and and
and all we're doing really though is we're just
taking some other discourse we heard on the
internet and just regurgitate here we don't
know how to form an opinion we have none of our
opinions what are we shows of this week what be
like in the last six days because that's what we
actually like what audience are we Playa to get
views let's oh boy comment below and let us know
what we think please that's what it's for and let
us know what to think next week so we can prepare
like subscribe and let us know how we [Music] feel